from jump scares to post-credit teasers
movie fake-outs are everywhere however
the most epic endings lull you into a
false sense of security
right before the big finale from classic
horror films to twisty crime tales
these are the most epic endings that no
one saw coming
prepare for spoilers based on the story
by stephen king
the mist has an ending so horrific that
it's become one of the most notorious
horror climaxes of
all time king's original tale ended in a
vague fashion
the survivors of the story drive away
with the hope of being rescued
but death is still a possibility we gave
it a good shot
nobody could say we didn't frank
darabon's cinematic adaptation however
goes even darker
the car runs out of gas and the five
survivors agree that they'd rather not
become a monster's afternoon snack
because there are only four bullets left
the main character shoots everyone
including his young son and is left
despairing
traumatized and ready to be devoured
it's an incredibly somber ending
and then he watches the military roll
into town
slaughter every creature in sight and
rescue
all the people they find on the way if
he could have waited just
five more minutes his friends and son
would still be alive
it's sick completely unexpected and an
utterly brilliant fake out joe wright's
vastly underrated period drama
atonement is one of the most
heart-wrenching portraits of class
division
and wartime trauma ever committed to
film
for most of the movie we follow the
miserable aftermath of upper class
cecelia and her working-class lover
robbie having their romance interrupted
by cecilia's little sister
brian she accuses him of a crime he
didn't commit
and robbie is sent off to war but
thankfully there's a happy ending
he finally reunites with cecilia and
bryony agrees to confess about her lie
and have the legal record changed so far
everything seems pretty cheery
i'm sorry could we stop for a moment
except that the ending is a big stinking
lie
we see that the satisfying climax we've
just watched was
fabricated by an elderly briony who is
now a famous writer
hoping to rewrite history and a tone for
her lies
in reality robbie died in dunkirk
and cecilia died two months later in a
tube station bombing
and now we're all crying
hot fuzz pays loving tribute to
hollywood action movie tropes
so we probably should have seen this
fake ending coming
sergeant nicholas angel uncovers the
truth about the neighborhood watch
association
the town elders of sanford are killing
anyone who might
ruin their chances of winning village of
the year
with a little help from a violent swan
he brings the operation leader into
custody
and everything seems to be tidally
wrapped up
while we're back at the station for a
cup of tea though
the last remaining villain bursts in and
shoots poor danny
but then in the ensuing struggle he
steps on a sea mine
and blows himself and the police station
up
for a moment there we think that danny
died
but the absolute final ending shows
danny surviving his gunshot wound
and leading the sanford cops with the
help of his bff
angel the surprise endings of the
endless saw sequels have become a bit of
a cliche
but when the first one was released in
2004
its fake ending genuinely caught people
off guard
and provided a terrifying climax for
horror fans
initially we're given an ending in which
the hospital worker
zepp is revealed to be the serial killer
all along
it doesn't make a lot of sense but the
reveal does prompt one of the captives
to saw off his own leg
so he can crawl out of his prison
meanwhile
adam the other captive kills zepp with a
toilet tank lid
good job everyone the end good
can i go home now the movie's actual
ending shows adam discovering that zepp
was actually a victim
not only that but the corpse that's been
lying in the middle of the room the
entire movie
stands up and reveals himself to be the
real killer
before abandoning a stunned atom in the
room alone to die
talk about a downbeat ending funny games
depicts a family whose vacation comes to
a screeching halt when two polite
psychopaths peter and paul
enter their lives to slowly torture and
kill them all
which they do very successfully
and by the end of the film only anne the
mom remains
in a natural and satisfying conclusion
anne grabs a shotgun
and kills peter with it finally grabbing
the upper hand
shouldn't have done that anne except
this is a movie where the villains have
complete control over the narrative
even breaking the fourth winking at the
camera as if the audience is an
accomplice to their
crimes with that in mind funny games
actual lending sees paul
using a tv remote to rewind the scene
itself
snatching the shotgun before ann can get
it and going on to enjoy the ending he
wants
that's awesome really really the house
of the devil is a throwback film set
against the satanic panic of the 1980s
and the characters have plenty of reason
to panic the plot follows samantha a
college student who accepts a job as a
babysitter
only to discover that she's actually
been hired to care for a mysterious
older woman as she investigates the
creepy house
samantha finds herself placed in the
middle of a bizarre satanic conception
ritual
courtesy of the creepy family who hired
her
samantha manages to escape and find
herself a gun like an absolute boss
but upon realizing she may now be a
vessel for something she'd rather
not be she chooses to shoot herself in
the head
in and of itself that's a gut punch of
an ending however
in the actual final ending samantha
survives the gunshot wound
and so does her unborn most definitely
satanic
child it's absolutely chilling
in 1979's alien ellen ripley
is having a really bad day at work she
just saw her workmates get turned into a
happy meal
and even witnessed one co-worker give
birth to a monster
via a ruptured chest cavity so yeah
it's a relief when ripley finally makes
it out of the whole thing in one piece
she escapes climbs into a shuttle and
finally
lets her guard down unbunch those
shoulders folks
it's a happy ending
but in a delightfully cruel twist
there's actually an alien
stowaway on board ripley's shuttle now
that ripley is relaxed and alone
she's all the more vulnerable thankfully
ripley also happens to be a one-woman
alien killing machine
and she manages to blast the toothy life
form safely out of the craft
so she can kick back with her cat and
live to see another day
it'll take more than one measly alien
and one
fake ending to defeat ellen ripley
okay so all the bohemian rhapsody
headbanging aside
wayne's world remains the highest
grossing movie based on a saturday night
live skit
and also helped usher in an era of
wonderfully self-aware cinema
following a narrative that pokes fun at
how much of american media
is designed to sell things to people
wayne's world provides a satisfying set
of false endings
it's like people only do things because
they get paid
and that's just really sad first there's
a sad ending where
everything that can go wrong does go
wrong with wayne smiling through a set
of flames as his basement goes up in
smoke
next up is the scooby-doo ending where
benjamin is revealed to be old man
withers from the haunted amusement park
that seems like it might bring the movie
to a close
but then wayne and garth opt to finish
with the mega happy ending
where everything is stupendous for
absolutely everyone
and it's air guitar solos and high fives
all around
in a baffling example of movie studios
thinking that u.s
audiences are too fragile the descent's
fake ending can only be found in the
original cut of the movie
which was screened in the uk it's a real
shame because the og ending features one
of the most brutal fake outs in cinema
history
after watching her entire friend group
get picked off by a set of
super ugly creatures sarah finally
escapes the cave
makes her way outside and sees a
hallucination of her recently deceased
friend as the screen fades to black
us audiences had the film finish here to
save their delicate souls
i knew it i knew this wasn't right for
uk viewers however
the movie resumes with the harrowing
truth sarah is still in the cave
she was simply hallucinating the entire
escape
worse still the crawlers can be heard
closing in on her as the screen cuts to
black
it's dark it's brutal and it's the only
way to end the film
the fake ending of the usual suspects is
probably one of the most iconic in
cinema history
back in a time when both director brian
singer and star kevin spacey were
well respected people in their industry
the film dropped such a bombshell that
it was all
anyone could talk about for years after
a suspenseful narrative
detective kuyan is sure that dean keaton
is the murderous crime lord kaiser soze
kuyan even gets a testimony from verbal
kint
a surviving witness with cerebral palsy
there's a certain sense of finality to
these scenes
and that's exactly what makes the
results all the more surprising
oh gee thanks dave bang-up job so far
we watch as kuyan slowly realizes that
verbal fabricated his entire deposition
and that's when we see the man we
thought was verbal slowly
losing his signature limp and flexing
his supposedly disabled hand
as the real kaiser soze exits stage left
and in plain sight not a single person
saw that ending coming at the time of
release
and we're still talking about that crazy
plot twist to this day
it's difficult to imagine the snapchat
generation quaking in their boots over a
cursed vhs tape
but in 2002 it was still pretty spooky
even now though the ring's fake ending
remains one of the scariest
the film draws to a nice wholesome
conclusion with rachel arranging a
proper burial for a vhs well-dwelling
corpse
the burial appears to lift the curse
from everyone
but it turns out that the corpse is a
bit of a tease
why did you do that though rachel has
been spared
the curse still exists for everyone else
who's watched the tape
including rachel's dopey ex-boyfriend
who watched it a week ago
and is now about to die a horrible death
rachel races to save the poor guy but by
the time she gets to him his face
is nothing but a deep-fried mess the
real conclusion is where rachel realizes
that she needs to copy the tape
and pass it along to another
unsuspecting fool
in order for her to save her son and
even though we're way past the era of
vhs tapes
the ending of the ring still makes us
nervous to turn on the tv
what about the person we show it to
what happens to them the 1976 adaptation
of stephen king's first novel
stunned and horrified audiences after
all it's your classic girl with
telekinetic powers meets boy
girl becomes prom queen girl massacres
her entire class before killing herself
and her abusive mother
high school romp it's intense to say the
least
so when we see the lone survivor
carrie's friend sue
visiting her grave to pay some final
respects it presents a much needed
moment of calm
despite everything sue still feels
remorse for how poorly carrie was
treated when she was alive
and it looks like we're closing out with
a somber yet satisfying conclusion
except it's not the finale instead
in one final scare carrie's hand
launches out of her grave and attacks
sue
in what's swiftly revealed to be a dream
sequence
teasing the idea of carries power beyond
the grave
modern audiences may be overly familiar
with such tricks
but in 1976 the ending messed people up
it's one of the greatest jump scares of
all time and [ __ ] spacek
even confessed that she used to go to
theaters just to watch the audience jump
out of their chairs
check out one of her newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one